los reguladores de Estados Unidos
incautaron El Fer República van y hoy se
lo han vendido a GP Morgan Chase en lo
que se conoce ya como la segunda caída
bancaria más importante en la historia
de este país y después de varios
intentos fallidos de rescate con más de
229 mil millones de dólares en activo en
el momento de cierre del cierre esta
mañana el ferre Republic Bank ya ha
abierto sus 84 sucursales en ocho
estados del país bajo la propiedad bajo
la red de GP Morgan Chase Por qué se da
esta situación Pues bien porque en su
balance trimestral presentado por
ferrepública van mostraban que han
perdido un 40% de los depositantes y
todo es ese efecto dominó provocado por
la quiebra del silicon Qué pasó que
cuando se produjo la quiebra de este
banco de California muchos depositantes
decidieron sacar su dinero de los bancos
medianos y ponerlos en donde son más
grandes en otros bancos más grandes y
que les ofrecían según ellos más
garantías Así que fue Republic Bank ha
sido uno de los bancos medianos más
afectados y este ha sido el resultado de
hecho según Banco América el 70% de sus
activos no estaban protegidos lo que
supone que estarían por encima de esos
250.000 dólares sin proteger que
permiten los reguladores de Estados
Unidos el presidente Joe biden ha dicho
en una conferencia en el día de hoy
desde la casa blanca que los
depositantes de ferrepublic Band pueden
estar tranquilos porque su dinero está
protegido ha celebrado la rápida
actuación de los reguladores de Estados
Unidos Les ha felicitado por facilitar
esta compra de ferrepublic Bank y aún
así ha pedido que haya una mayor
regulación un mayor control en los
medianos y grandes bancos de Estados
Unidos